[Music]
our community is very isolated
having good internet has always been a
struggle having starlink we feel spoiled
now
because we can do whatever we want
there's only three pieces of equipment
you know there's a router
a dish and a big long cable
these dishes connect to internet
providing satellites that have been
launched into space like this
three two one zero
ignition the system is called starlink
and it's the new much-hyped satellite
internet service from elon musk's spacex
it looks like a ufo on a stick there's
just two instructions and they can be
done in either order a pointed sky
plug in instead of using underground
cords and cables
starlink uses low orbiting satellites to
bring internet to remote communities
that's all 60 of those starling
satellites one of the first communities
the macaw reservation on the
northwestern tip of washington state
it's about 170 miles west of seattle and
two hours from the closest walmart
since starlink is still in limited
testing we travel to this remote corner
of the u.s
to talk to a number of beta testers and
put starlink to the test
to see if it's really the solution to
the global broadband gap
[Music]
most residents who have internet
connectivity here deal with slow speeds
and service that falters during bad
weather
i have century link for my house i
can't access zoom meetings
and that's part of my work and i can't
do that
[Music]
it'll crash i've tried it a few times
and it crashes
i play this game and it's called cookie
jam
and it takes about five five minutes
to get going you can play like about
three levels and then it will stop
get into that split position remember
front foot out
weight on the ball of your foot yep back
heels up just slightly
up the street from cindy starlink beta
tester glenn ellis isn't only video
calling
he's live streaming personal training
sessions and then your hips are going to
move backwards
okay as you lower down then you're gonna
come back up nice and aggressive squeeze
your butt
really hard i'm gonna add some more
weight
i work for the maca tribe organization
first i'm the preventative health
director
in my off time i'm a personal trainer i
run a
personal training program online in
order to be more
profitable and have a bigger reach i
need to be able to expand to other
communities
five of them here we go but with the
internet limitations it wasn't possible
the the biggest things that we're able
to do is have
multiple heavy usage uh devices on
the internet at once nice job
yep this is only a two gigabyte
video file but you know with our old
speeds it would have been impossible to
to upload
down the hill from glenn jason roberts
is also psyched about faster upload
speeds
he makes a living doing audio and video
production
[Music]
we asked jason and his family to use
multiple data-heavy devices at the same
time
[Music]
while jason reviewed a youtube video he
shot and edited
his toddler son hunter watched cartoons
all while his wife stella made a
facetime call
and his other sons played a data hungry
video game that they simultaneously
streamed to youtube
starling seemed to hold up just fine
over the course of a few days
we asked glenn and jason to run a bunch
of speed tests
plugged into his router jason got
download speeds around 148 megabits per
second
and upload speeds of 13.6 megabits per
second
that's still below the us average which
is 180 megabits per second for downloads
and 66 megabits per second for uploads
but it's far faster than centurylink
the main internet service provider on
the reservation which saw download
speeds barely above 1 megabits per
second
and an upload speed of 0.50 megabits per
second
still starlink seems to be the best
option around so how does it bring
internet to the middle of nowhere
the starlink dishes that dot the macaw
reservation connect to low orbiting
satellites that fly about 550 kilometers
above
earth according to spacex that's over 60
times closer to earth than the
geosynchronous orbits used by some of
its competitors
this minimizes the delay of the signal
from the space satellites to the end
users who receive internet service
that's what enables starlink's internet
speeds to be faster than previous
satellite internet service providers
like hughesnet and viasat but there's a
downside to that closer proximity to
earth
it means way more satellites floating
around starlink's constellation of
satellites will likely have to grow into
the tens of thousands to meet elon
musk's goal
of providing internet service around the
globe
right now the range has given us a green
light for launch
in the meantime questions about the
viability and repercussions of
starlink's mission
are beginning to bubble up spacex did
not respond to questions we raised about
[Music]
starlink
check this out starlink
the biggest issue with starlink may be
the cost
for those with limited financial
resources it's a barrier
new customers pay almost 500 in initial
equipment fees and i'm going to tell you
right now
the hype is real then there's a 99
monthly fee for the service it's a 500
that i couldn't afford right now at this
moment
the cost is definitely a barrier for
many especially in our community
we have a really high unemployment rate
during
non-tourist season some people don't
have
any income for a large portion of the
year due to seasonal work
there's you know there's logging and
then there's fishing
in nia bay where most residents on the
macau reservation live
the poverty rate is around 30 percent
according to 2019 census bureau figures
that compares to 10.5 percent nationally
in fact the poverty rate in most rural
counties across the u.s
is 16.3
the macaw tribe is exploring ways to
bring better internet to the reservation
at low cost
but for now most residents have access
through either dsl
or geostationary satellite providers
today in nia bay it'll be rainy with a
forecasted high of 47 and a low of 44.
so far weather hasn't been a problem for
two of the starlink families we visited
other beta testers haven't had such luck
terry de beau lives just outside the
reservation
she teaches head start and signed up for
starlink after classes went online due
to the pandemic
i don't know if it's because of the
trees and the mountain behind
me if it's rainy if it's cloudy
or if it's windy my service isn't that
good
when i get dropped off my zoom calls i'm
you know going to continue to use it but
i wish
it was more consistent
technical support is also an issue for
some
starlink has a chat box for tech support
but there isn't a phone number and the
company doesn't send
out technicians jason roberts
frequently makes house calls to
neighbors with starling to help
troubleshoot issues
ranging from bill payment to
displacement i reached out to a lot of
community members and
helped people get set up with starlink
i've done about four installs so far
one of the biggest reasons that we
really need good internet access here in
nia bay is that
we're so isolated here and we rely on
internet for everything
i think our community can benefit from
better internet for
a lot of reasons but the main reason is
the opportunities here are not great for
a lot of people
it's a small community and the funding
is very limited
to get kids experiences off of the
reservation
everybody knows that song i know that's
what she's saying though
and so sometimes kids don't know what
they're interested in
because they've never been exposed to it
most people don't you know they don't
know what they're missing
without it